c'est un grand homme d'affaires qui
s'éteint un pionnier du québec inc né à
montréal en 1921 genre de grand prix va
se hisser à la tête de bell canada un
des postes les plus prestigieux au pays
à l'époque où il était le pays d'est les
affaires s'étaient surtout anglophone
mais c'est quelqu'un qui était très fier
d'être francophone qui parlait un
français impeccable
une des choses que je tienne mon pinceau
qui a toujours dit stone décisions à
prendre par là parce que la pire
décision c'est celle que tu prendras
jamais
si j'ai bonne tant mieux si tu te
trompes reconnaître une erreur
recommence règle le problème jean deux
grands prix entre chez bell en 1966 puis
devient le président et chef de la
direction de l'entreprise sept ans plus
tard il fonde le conglomérat bce en 1983
ce qui permettra à bell de devenir un
géant des télécommunications
quand je suis arrivé c'était uniquement
une compagnie de téléphone quand je suis
parti c'était une compagnie de
télécommunications et qui aurait une
réputation internationale
sous sa gouverne belle décrochent des
contrats sur les cinq continents pour
implanter et moderniser des systèmes de
télécommunications notamment en arabie
saoudite
la compagnie en fait du profit
extraordinaire avec le contrat ouais en
arabie saoudite nous avons obtenu la
réputation internationale d'être la plus
la meilleure compagnie de téléphone
etc
en 1984 il devient le 15e chancelier de
l'université mcgill
puis de la retraite jusqu'à son dernier
souffle il se concentre sur la
philanthropie notamment auprès de la
fondation papillon un organisme qui
offre des séjours en plein air aux
enfants handicapés et autistes le cactus
aide les enfants mais gilles a aidé
également beaucoup les parents un homme
généreux un homme de coeur
le président de la fondation perd non
seulement un partenaire mais aussi un
ami jean de grandpré venait tout juste
de financer la construction de nouveaux
bâtiment aucun doute hubble parc ce
monsieur a marqué ma vie
c'est un homme vrai un homme freins ils
disent à jamais le contraire de ce
qu'ils pensaient alors on savait à quoi
s'en tenir avec lui les gens aimaient
travailler avec lui parce que c'est une
personne très chaleureuse sympathique
qui écoutait et qui respectait les
autres genres de grand prix aura marqué
le milieu des affaires mais aussi les
gens qui l'ont côtoyé
ici olivier bachand radio canada
montréal